Daniel: Hi my name is Dan Shapiro, I am director
of the Harvard International Negotiation program,
and it's an honor to talk with you all today
on the YouTube community.
A global priority as I see it is to build
more effective processes, institutions, ways
of dealing with conflict. Conflict that has
a huge cost on our society today.
There was a recent study done in the Middle
East showing that in the past twenty years,
the cost of conflict has been approximately
twelve trillion dollars.
Imagine what that region would look like with
a surplus of that nature, what the institutions
could look of education and so on.
Thats just the Middle East, we look at the
rest of the world as well. The cost of conflict
is huge, and what can we do about it.
The problem is that our world is very focused
right now on reacting to conflict. On dealing
with it after the fact. Assuming that destructive
conflict, violent conflict is a natural state
of human being, rather than saying what can
we do to try to prevent violent conflict,
destructive conflict from occurring in the
first place.
Myself and a number people at global [Inaudible]
council here at the world economic forum,
one that focuses on negotiation, colleagues
at Harvard, are all at a concerted way working
to build new models, new ways practically
of preventing violent conflict before it even
occurs.
One of the things I would encourage you to
do and all of us to do is to try to build
into our educational system and institutions
curriculum, trainings on conflicts resolution
and negotiation so that we could build the
capacity for peace and for people to deal
with conflict more effectively, ultimately
towards a more secure and stable world.
I look forward to hearing all of the good
work you are doing and thank you for listening
to me today.